All right, I'll just go in order.
I'll start with the three
boxes we see here.
Each box takes up a third of the page.
So I'll set their width to 33%, and
the orders will go up sequentially.
One, two, and three.
On the next row down, the dark green.
And the orange boxes are both
taking up 50% of view port, so
as their widths to 50% and
their orders are four and five.
And lastly there's another element that
takes up the full width of the view
ports this would be something probably
like a footer on the page, and
because it goes the whole view
port width it has a width of 100%.
And I set its order to
six because it's last.
You might have decided to give each
element a different order number, and
that's totally fine, so long as
they're in the right sequential order.
I could have just as easily picked
increasing prime numbers, but
that would've just been silly.